♪ ♪
>> Tucker: JUST BEFORE THE
BREAK YOU HEARD THE FOUNDER OF
BLACKWATER ERIC PRINCE, REMEMBER
THE TIME THAT HIS MEN RESCUED
JOE BIDEN AND JOHN KERRY FROM TN
CONTROL AFGHANISTAN.
FOR A BRAND-NEW EPISODE OF
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT,"
JOINING US ON SIDE AND GAVE US
THE PERSPECTIVE OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN AFGHANISTAN NOW.
WHY IT HAPPENED AND WHAT IT
TELLS US ABOUT THE LEADERSHIP OF
THIS COUNTRY, HERE IS PART
CONVERSATION.
♪ ♪
WHAT EFFECT DOES THIS HAVE?
YOU HAVE WORKED IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES AND LIKELY
STILL ARE, WHAT EFFECT IS THIS
GOING TO HAVE ON THE REST OF THE
WORLD?
THEY ARE PRETTY CLEAR LESSONS
FROM THIS, ARE THERE NOT?
>> MUCH MORE THAN THE DEMOCRATS
ARE LOOKING AND PLANNING ABOUT
TRUMP DAMAGING NATO, THIS WILL
DESTROY WHAT IS LEFT OF NATO
BECAUSE THEY HAVE SO UNILATERAL
AND SO CLUELESS FOR THE
PRESIDENT IN THE UNITED STATES
TO BE REBUKED IN THE HOUSE OF
PARLIAMENT IS THE FIRST TIME IT
HAS EVER HAPPENED.
SO WE HAVE SHATTERED THE
COMPETENCE OF OUR EUROPEAN
ALLIES AND EVERY OTHER ALLY
AROUND THE WORLD THAT AMERICA
DEPENDS WHETHER YOU ARE A CIA
AGENT TRYING TO RECRUIT SOMEBODY
TO WORK FOR YOU OR WHETHER YOU
ARE A COUNTRY THAT AMERICA WANTS
YOU TO COMPETE TO SIDE WITH US
VERSUS SOMETHING THAT THE
CHINESE WANT, IT WILL DEFINITELY
FIGURE INTO PEOPLE'S THINKING
HOW QUICKLY AMERICA ABANDONS
THEIR FRIENDS IN AFGHANISTAN AND
LEFT IN SUCH A HORRIBLY CHAOTIC
AND CLUMSY MANNER AND SO, THEY
ARE GOING TO BE PURE MUTATIONS
IN ALL SIDES WE HAVE NOT EVEN
THOUGHT OF YET THAT COME FROM
THIS.
BECAUSE LOOK, THE DOLLAR IS THE
WORLD'S RESERVE CURRENCY, WHY?
BECAUSE IT IS UNDERPINNED BY THE
NOTION OF U.S. MILITARY
STRENGTH, AND WHAT WE ARE SEEING
UNFOLD IN AFGHANISTAN OVER THE
LAST 20 YEARS AND OVER THE LAST
FEW WEEKS IN THE NEXT TWO WEEKS
REALLY DOES NOT SHOW WELL.
I CALLED THREE YEARS AGO, LET'S
PREVENT THE HELICOPTER OFF THE
ROOFTOP MOMENT IN SAIGON, AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE GOT.
>> Tucker: YOU MENTION WE ARE
THE STATUS OF THE WORLD
CURRENCY, SO THAT IS CENTRAL TO
THE ECONOMY.
>> CENTRAL TO THE ECONOMY
BECAUSE WE DEFICIT SPENDING CAN
DO THAT BECAUSE WE CAN PRINT
MORE AND MORE DOLLARS.
BUT IF PEOPLE DON'T REGARD THE
UNITED STATES AS THE SOLE -- AS
THE FOX AMERICANA GOES AWAY AND
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT CONFIDENCE
IN THE DOLLAR THAT HAS MASSIVE
TRICKLE-DOWN IMPLICATIONS TO OUR
ECONOMY AND WAY OF LIFE.
>> Tucker: NO RESERVE CURRENCY
COLLAPSE OF ECONOMY, TOTAL RESET
ON THE STANDARD OF LIVING,
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT COUNTRY.
>> THE SAME WAY YOU LIVE IN
ARMENIA.
THE ABOLITION OF THE WELFARE
STATE, MASSIVE, MASSIVE CHANGES,
FAR GREATER CONVULSIONS THAN THE
GREAT DEPRESSION OR ANY OTHER
CIVIL UNREST WE HAVE HAD IN
AMERICA.
>> Tucker: SO THE BIGGER POINT
YOU'RE MAKING IS WHEN THE
COUNTRY IN CONTROL OF THE WORLD
REVEALS ITSELF AS WEAK, THE
WORLD BECOMES MUCH MORE
VOLATILE.
>> WHEN IT REVEALS IT IS
DEFEATED BY PEOPLE USING
70-YEAR-OLD WEAPONS THAT ARE
LIVING IN A MIND-SET OF THE
SIXTH CENTURY THAT MAY BE THAT
U.S. IS NOT AS CAPABLE AS THEY
ESPOUSE THEMSELVES TO BE.
AS THE COSPLAY PEOPLE DESCRIBE
THEMSELVES TO BE.
I DON'T CARE HOW MUCH
SURVEILLANCE YOU HAVE, WHAT DOES
IT DO TO THE REALITY OF THE
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND?
>> Tucker: YOU JUST HEARD
LLOYD AUSTIN, THE FORMER DEFENSE
CONTRACTOR ARE NOW RUNNING THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE THAT THE
REAL THREAT HE WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND ALL OF US IS WHITE
SUPREMACY IN THE UNITED STATES,
SOUNDS LIKE MAYBE THERE IS A
SHIFT HAVING BEEN DEFEATED BY
THE TALIBAN TO THE ENEMY HERE AT
HOME, DO YOU WORRY ABOUT THAT?
>> I FIND IT AMAZING HOW WORRIED
EVERYONE IS ABOUT COVID THAT THE
TALIBAN MANAGED TO CONQUER THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY WITHOUT WEARING
MASKS AND COVID DID NOT SEEM TO
SLOW THEM DOWN TOO MUCH.
SO I THINK LET'S WORRY ABOUT THE
BIG THREATS AND YES, COVID CAN
BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY, BUT WE DON'T
NEED TO SHUT DOWN THE ECONOMY.
THE AMERICAN ECONOMY, THE
MACHINE, PEOPLE HAVE TO GET BACK
TO WORK AND SCHOOL AND KEEP
LIVING.
>> Tucker: ERIC PRINCE, ONE OF
THE MOST KNOWLEDGEABLE PEOPLE IN
THE WORLD